vamos a la revista de prensa con Marta
Moya Como cada mañana Marta Buen día
para usted Feliz lunes Ángela igual
Marta pero con muchas noticias vamos a
abrir en El Salvador este lunes ha
estado en nuestros titulares lo hemos
avanzado desde el inicio de directo
América se cumple un año de la
implementación del régimen de excepción
que deja números preocupantes a todas
las escalas Aunque mucha popularidad
para el presidente nayib bukele y esto
lo recoge el medio Alfaro Así es Ángela
vamos a retrotraernos un poco a cuando
empezó todo esto nos situamos el 27 de
marzo de 2022 cuando ese fin de semana
deja 87 muertos por la violencia de las
pandillas Y entonces bukele bueno
sirviéndose de esa mayoría absoluta en
la asamblea legislativa propone
presentar este régimen de excepción que
ya dejó de ser excepcional por su
prórroga ininterrumpida durante 11 meses
consecutivos una investigación de El
Faro decía que todo ese repunte de la
violencia del año se debía a una
venganza de la Mara Salvatrucha que es
la mara y la pandilla más popular en El
Salvador por la detención de algunos de
sus miembros mientras regía una especie
de pacto entre el gobierno y la mara que
trataba de menos violencia a cambio de
beneficios penitenciarios y apoyo en las
elecciones legislativas de 2021 bukele
siempre ha negado este extremo El caso
es que Esto ocurrió y un año después
según cifras oficiales son más de 65.000
los detenidos una restricción total de
derechos constitucionales ha habido
denuncias del movimiento de trabajadores
de la policía por las que se decía que
se les pedía unas cuotas diarias de
detenidos y también ha habido denuncias
de torturas desapariciones forzadas
muertes en las cárceles y detenciones
arbitrarias por parte de amnistía o
incluso Naciones Unidas sobre los 65.000
detenidos dice el faro que es imposible
determinar si el gobierno cuenta a
aquellas personas que recién liberadas
vuelven a ser detenidas Justo a las
puertas de los penales o aquellos que
han sido capturados liberados y
recapturados durante el régimen de
excepción según el ministro de seguridad
del Salvador Solo han sido liberadas
3.300 personas en este último año y si
se toman como es reales las cifras que
emite el gobierno Pues estamos hablando
de que hay un 2% de la población
salvadoreña encarcelada esto es la tasa
de encarcelamiento más alta de todo el
mundo hay que decir que en medio de esto
si uno le pregunta a la población hay
una gran sensación de seguridad hay
gente que Alaba pues estas medidas de
nayib bukele Pese a que digamos van
contra los derechos internacionales
ahora a raíz de este mismo tema y
hablando de esas violaciones que se
denuncian a los Derechos Humanos el
medio del país se lleva en su portada un
reportaje web que nos da los testimonios
de ex reclusos salvadoreños detenidos
Durante este último año y luego puestos
en libertad por falta de pruebas si
Ángela nos referimos a este reportaje
que narra los este testimonios de dos
excarcelados en El Salvador Por una
parte Manuel con un hombre ficticio Un
hombre de unos 40 años y por otra parte
dolores almendrales de 53 años esta
mujer sí que quiso dar su nombre real
ambos Fueron liberados por falta de
pruebas Manuel dice por ejemplo que
desde que entró en abril de 2022 hasta
febrero de este año nunca vio la luz del
sol es mucho tiempo sin ver la luz del
sol vivía en una celda con 70 reclusos
más en una celda que estaba bueno
acondicionada para 20 personas sólo
había un retrete se turnaban en turnos
de dos tres horas para dormir sentados
dice Manuel que vio morir a un compañero
de celda que era diabético y nadie le
estaba insuflando esa insulina ningún
médico acudía a las celdas para Bueno
trasladarle este este tratamiento y que
vio morir a otro compañero de 21 años
un día le pegaron tanto que lo mataron a
golpes y lo sacaron a rastras como un
animal denuncian que eran habituales
también esos manguerazos de agua y
cuando el suelo estaba mojado en la
celda activaban la pistola de corriente
eléctrica para que sufrieron las
descargas todos los reclusos dolores por
su parte fue acusada de extorsión en el
mes de Mayo sin pruebas no le dejaron
hablar con ningún abogado y dice
textualmente que en la primera noche que
pasó en prisión el policía les dijo aura
ahora ustedes son el blanco les puedo
pegar un tiro ahora mismo y decir que se
querían fugar pues mire Marta este tema
está abierto la discusión más adelante
con el primer invitado del día vamos a
ampliar un poco el análisis pero le voy
a pedir que cambiemos rápidamente otro
de los titulares de la jornada con la
atención en aumento en Israel por la
reforma judicial si Ángela y hemos
destacado el medio jareds que hace un
minuto a minuto de todo lo que va
aconteciendo en esta jornada de huelga
nacional se está bueno está esperando a
que hable el ministro el Primer Ministro
Benjamin natanyahu Que de momento no lo
ha hecho en Twitter Llamando a la calma
pero se podría pronunciar para poner en
congelamiento esa reforma judicial que
ha sido tan polémica este Minuto a
minuto de jareds dice que universidades
bancos aeropuertos y centros comerciales
están este lunes en huelga que hay
movilizaciones masivas tanto en tel aviv
como en Jerusalén que el grupo de
extrema derecha A la familia también ha
llamado a sus fieles a movilizarse
frente al parlamento y que la policía
teme enfrentamientos violentos entre
aquellos que rechazan la reforma y los
que la defienden también hay malestar en
el seno del gobierno de israelí y se
podría incluso estar pensando en
restituir al ministro que fue ayer
dimitido incluso venga a vivir el líder
de extrema derecha a de la coalición ha
dicho que amenaza con romper la
coalición si Benjamín natanyahu no lleva
adelante esta reforma es que no hay nada
que pueda parar esas protestas que a
propósito Marta son imágenes en directo
las que tenemos en la pantalla y muy
rápidamente vamos a terminar con una
noticia más amable hemos conocido a un
escritor colombiano que se convirtió en
el autor hispano más traducido del mundo
si Ángela nos referimos a Gabriel García
Márquez esto según el mapa mundial de la
traducción del instituto Cervantes que
se va a presentar la próxima semana en
el noveno congreso de la lengua en Cádiz
Esta es una producción de metadatos
sobre las obras publicadas y traducidas
a 10 idiomas y es lo que llevamos de
Siglo XXI Márquez Isabel Allende y Jorge
Luis Borges son los tres autores
hispanos más traducidos a otros idiomas
concretamente el autor colombiano es el
autor más traducido al árabe al Ruso y
al portugués Pues ahí lo tenemos muchas
gracias a usted Marta y nos vemos mañana
gracias Ángela